はいいい
みなさんこんにちはう
ご紹介いただきました渋谷区長の発売犬です
腐食彫刻8うわ come to スヴィア3
ちょっとことが大きいからん
実はまあこういったテッドで喋らせているのが今回で2回目です最初の委員会
ディレクターけど喋らせていただいて教
この ir 6種ビアのスタートの日のトップバッターを数えていただきました a
大変光栄だてぃパートナー話
をしようかっていうことはちょっといろいろ考えてきたんですけども
今あの
まあ渋谷がカーラーとしていますこれがどういうふうに変わっていくかというとこう
話させて頂ければと思います
割とこういったステージ話す機会が多かったのはまぁ前回のはティル gbt 生
パートナーシップ証明書まあその一連の流れのインタビューが一番多かったんですけど
も今日
ちょっと切り離してこの街がこれからどういう風な未来図を描いていこうとしているか
ということを皆さんと共有させていただいてええ
またそこでいろんなインスパイアーしていたしていただいてですね
こうアイデアがまた集まってくるそんな街になればいいなという思いでお話しさせて
いただきます
最初はちょっと動画を見ていただこうと思いますこれは実は8
京都の未来ビジョン懇談会というですねまぁ知事の下で
東京の未来をみんなで想像していこうという人達が集まってプレゼンテーションを行う
場がありましたそこでへ長として参加して
ブーブーなんですけどもまぁちょっと観ていただいてそのちょっと補足しながらティ
していただければと思いますじゃあお願いします
[音楽]
インターネットから始まったオープンイノベーションの波は様々な技術革新をもたらし
c 今や第4次産業革命とも呼ばれる
新しい時代が始まろうとしています
[音楽]
常にトレンドの発信地として注目を集め今も再開発プロジェクトを通じて未来都市へと
変貌し続ける街渋谷
[音楽]
この街から世界に先駆けて新たなサービスを育て
文化として発信していく
渋谷をそんなインキュベーションシティ東京へと帰る為に
渋谷区クリエイティブシティ特区プロジェクトが始動します
[音楽]
多様化するコミュニケーションに対応し次世代エンターテインメントを実現させるため
5 c ネットワークの社会実験プロジェクトを計画
接続環境を意識しないシームレスなインターネット接続と高速かつ大容量のデータ通信
を可能にすることで様々な iot サービスを実現します
次世代型エンターテイメントの媒体として街の景観に溶け込んだ
液面デジタルサイネージを設置
東京オリンピックではあぶりっくビューイングとして
災害緊急時にはアラート装置として公共性の高い目的のために活用しながら収益の地域
還元も行う
コミュニティサイネージとして機能します
クリエイティブシティ渋谷のシンボルである最新テクノロジーを駆使した
世界標準のエンターテインメント施設スポーツイベントから音楽フェスライブイベント
パンはレンズに至るまで様々な利用シーンを想定したハイブリッドな空間です
[音楽]
さらに渋谷は電気べーションシティとして
次世代テクノロジーを活用しながら未来型都市へと変貌します
ブロックチーンの技術を生かした地域通貨と決済機能を実現する
good がねぇ渋谷
インバウンド旅行者向けに多言語翻訳機能を備える
ar レストラン検索
著名人のプログラムと記念撮影ができる音もやるスポットを設置し収益をチャリティー
に還元する
ビットバレーミュージアム
[音楽]
アスリートやアーティストなどの登場人物を再現主会場に行かなくても
監修との一体感や臨場感を体験できるデジタルスタジアム
[音楽]
ファッションストリート2
ar を使った新しい形の o 2 o マーケティング施策を実現する
ar ストリートファッションショー
エコロジカルかつ安全で快適
エンターテインメント性のある移動手段を可能にする
new mobility
まだ起業家を育成するインキュベーションセンターの運営を通じてヨーロッパアメリカ
などのハイテク都市を結び
アジアのテクノロジーハブとしての機能を担うプログラムも提供していきます
ゆんきゅべーションセンター渋谷
エンジニア education
[音楽]
そして世界を代表するエンターテインメントシティを実現するため劇場
all
映画館ライブハウスクラブなどのエンターテイメントスペースを併設した施設の開発に
採取
容積率を緩和してコワーキングスペースやソーシャルアパートメントなどに向けた
増床を可能にします
[音楽]
私たちが夢見た未来を実現する2020クリエイティブシティ渋谷は東京2分を世界へ
発信する国際成熟都市として進化していきます
違いを力に変える町
渋谷区
はいありがとうございます
eme
でもここで今描いたのは決して遠い未来ではなくて割とこれは近い未来のイメージで
考えました
でテクノロジーの部分ついてももう今すでにあるテクノロジーもう
手前にすぐそこにあるテクノロジー桜の想定してます
まず最初はあの5 g というところから始まりました
ってこれはもう本当にあと2年先その暗いとこまできてるんじゃ
ないかなと思いますでやっぱり僕は思っているのはその行政だけで街づくりっていうの
はできないというふうに思うんです
で口調になってあの女性はどんな街ですかいいましてどんなティっていうふうに
インタビューパティオわけないじゃないと思うんですけども
あえて言うならばいつも思ってい使っているのは
gt プライドがたくさん集まる街だという風に表現しています
僕はこの街で生まれ育ってよ16年ももうすぐで
でまぁずっとこの街の変化を見てきました子供の頃がまあ自分の街がどんな街かつだっ
た街がどんな街かってことはよくわかってませんでしただけど
例えば中学校が僕は原宿中学校という名前の隣の駅の中学校ですけども
その中学校に行ってる時にはやっぱりみんな here 前の中学校でああ
庄野町の名前の中学校ですから塾行ったり部活で他の犬とシェアしたりすると
here till 人ってもうこの街が最先端をいっていていろんな人が注目して
るってこと
が住んでいる僕らのシティプライドになってきました
でこれは一つ本当に重要なことだと思います
ファッションまたはまああととか
まあいろんな映画とかいろんなカルチャーがこの街から生まれてます
でもそれは住民とか行政が作ってきたものではやっぱりなくてこの街が好きだなーとか
好きだなあと思う人たちまたは企業とか
このマティいるがティ
卒業したけどまたこの街を第二の国土を守ってくれるとそういった子が多いが集まって
そういったカルチャー文化が生まれてきていると思います
そういうものが評価されるから住んでいる僕らもやっぱりプライドが保ててきた
まあ多分そのシティプライドが僕は高まって今の仕事をしてるんじゃないかなという
ふうに思います
そういったときにやっぱり今まで
は行政だけで済んでる人だけでまちづくりのことを考えていましたけれども
もっとそれを広げて間口を広げて
記事を働いてる人また学んでる人を好きで遊びに来る人
そういった人々がこの街のステークホルダーだというふうに思います
ただで政治家ですからまあたペアだったり投票権のある人というのは当然その日あり
ますがでも広げてみんなと一緒になって考えていくそれが必要だというふうに思って
ます
今渋谷区は20年先のビジョンとしてですねこれ口調になって一番最初に飛びつくんだ
仕事だったんですけども
基本構想っていうものを改定しましたっぺ基本構想っていうのは地方自治体がそれぞれ
オリジナルで持っていて基本計画って言うところありますその自治体の政策の最上位
来年に来ているものになります僕らはそれを元にして10カ年の経過がおつくったり5
年とか残念だとか
すべての政策がその基本構想に紐付いている構図になっています
その基本構想に10年ぶりに改めて次の20年先を見据えた基本構想に変えましたこれ
は違いを力に変える町渋
薬という風に
設定しました違いを力に変える magique 役
多くの人がですねそこで混じり合って
お互いを認め合ってですね性別や国籍や
この街に何年住んでいるかとか趣味趣向とかいろんなものを超えてお互いが実は違うん
だってことを認めアティク右側ねまじアティ
そうですでそれをあの実践していくにあたってアウトプットとしては一つはさっきの
目地た映像のようなですねああいった世界観
または
まぁ前回の程度でお話しましたがそのいろんな同性愛者含めてですね
みんながこの街で生き生きとこう暮らしていけるような
まあそういった条例だったりまあ仕組みを作っていくことがやっぱり重要だという風に
考えています
でちょちょっと映像の話に戻しますとそういった概念のもとへさぁ5 g
行政でできる話はありませんからやっぱり民間事業者と組んでさらに言うとテスト的に
最初にこの渋谷区でやってもらえば
またそこで新しいテクノロジーが集まってイノベーションが起きて渋谷らしいたち文化
をもっと持ってこの街から発進してくるな数値になるじゃないから今日この後で大丈夫
のサイトさんもから離しあります
どもまあ今日はアンシア山5ジーター直接はないかもしれませんがでもそこで今主役と
取り組んでいる話がそういった環境のこともっともっと表現できるような場所になるん
じゃないかなということも思っていますもう一つ
この街の大きな大きなやっぱり航空機として僕が強く感じているのはやっぱりこう
いろんな人が出会って混じり合って何かを生み出していく
これはファッションもそうでしたしさっき言ったアートの世界もそうでしたずっとこの
街はそういうことが起きてます
これをいかにして伸ばしていくかということだと思うんです
特にそのクリエイティブの領域とかまあ今でいうその it 系のイノベーションを
着るようなそういった領域っていうのはこれから渋谷区の大きな演じ
なると思いますさっき言った img だけじゃなくてエンターテインメントとかそう
いったクリエイティビティをどう集めてくるかっていうときにやっぱりも大きな課題は
場所がなかなかありませんこういったスペースも
本当に稀で本来だのこれもっと大きくたっていいじゃないですか公演数ですがでも
やっぱりなかなかないんですね
であれば例えばですけども最後の方に出てましたけど
コンサートホールを造ったり
here スペースをつくった場合は新しくビルを建て替える時に容積が麻痺 i6森
ありますしそういったことはまちの安心安全にも非常につながる話だと思います
こういったことをっぐですけども
ブーブー言ったアーマーれキルヒアイス
あってできないのでドックでやっていきたいでこのまちの課題とした
ハロウィンとかカウントダウンとかまぁ皆映像をご覧な here 僕らが頼んで
集まって来てもらってるわけではなくて有り難いことに皆さんこの日あってゴミの問題
とかいい近隣の人としたら1日中夜中まで騒がれて迷惑だとか
そういうのがありますであればこの行動を有料制にしてイベントをしてですね
事前に登録した人参加料を払った人たちがそのお金でゴミの面倒を見ればいいですし
例えば顔に以上でそこに入れるようにすれば警察も警備がしやすい
そういったことも実は今屋外高校月正常
ひぁっできてないんですそういったものもこのトップを使ってこうやっていきたいと
いうふうに考えております
でこれはそういうことを行政だけではなくてやっぱりそのやりたい人たちとやっぱり
くってやっていく必要があると思いますそのさらにアクラをかけるために今度の四月
から今ちょうど渋谷杭害虫なんですけども
この議会でその4月から始めたいと思っている
渋谷未来デザインというですね新しい一般社団法人
この提案をしておりますでこれは例えばですけども
あのさっき言った5 g だってそれぞれの正
here イメージ
リングがあってですね
南の端っこが恵比寿疲労度方で
北の端っこが家の甲州街道の方なんですね笹塚の方になります
あっちのエリアをもっともっと面白くしたいと思ったときに
[音楽]
here 一年中誰がとっても g
ふうにしていいよななんか
なんていうか野菜とか果物がずっと are here そのすぐ横に行こうっていう
日本へ here けど伊予たらその伊藤園と組んでやればですね
お墓も作ってもらえたらヤバイことを買ってないんですよ
あの日あの時もその1年のお金で作ってもらうことができるんじゃないか
すべてを税金でやるんじゃなくてそういった企業のやりたい csr 的なところと
組んでやっていけばどんどんできるんじゃないかにょやるのはちょっと苦手なところが
あるのでそれを一般社団法人として相当に出してですね3
人間と市民とみんなが高層初し合って新しいアイデアそれを実装していく
そういったことをどんどん進めるプロジェクトそれがあの守備は未来デザインっていう
のを始めます是非
4月からスタートするんでネットとかでちょっとチェックしていただいてですね僕も
変えたい私も変わりたいってこよどんどん寄せていただいてこの街を皆さんと一緒に
りあげたいなというふうに思っております
ちょっと時間も限られてるんでそのたくさん話せないんですけども
あの今のようなですねいろいろみんなとこうタッグを組みながら街を作っていくって
ことがこれから渋谷区の大きなテーマです
ご承知の通り支部駅周辺そっちのある区役所
また国立競技場東今大きな工事が進んでいて
街の景色が大きく変わってきていますでもこう
こんな時だからこそ改めて地域のコミュニティ
あの街にあるコミュニティ子の絆を更に強くしていってですねそこがつながりあって
混じり合って新しいシナジーを起こしていく
そういった街にしたいなというふうに思っておりますあの部長としては決して好上に
立ってあの偉そうにするんじゃなくてですね
here 盛り上げていただければと言う
ふうに思います今年の渋谷区のテーマ
酒歯基本構想を実現するための言葉として使っている言葉があります
いうメーカー geru ducati これ日本語でもよくよピュアメイク渋谷って
いうふうにも来ると思うんですよもっと
こうそういった意味を持っておりますのでぜひそういった言葉を組めて主役を好きに
なって頂ければというふうに思いますこいつはどうもありがとうございます
[拍手]